another coveted wave the sixth if you're
keeping count is washing over the
country ontario is the latest province
to make a second booster shot a fourth
vaccine available as early as tomorrow
to anyone over the age of 60 along with
vulnerable groups that's going to be
really important for people to get that
extra level of protection the move comes
as hospitalizations have risen in
ontario from 611 two weeks ago to a
thousand seventy four an increase of
over seventy percent and measurements of
wastewater in ontario suggests covet
levels are higher now than at any time
in the past the wastewater virus is
going up very vigorously indeed it's a
kind of an early warning system and all
across ontario especially eastern
ontario those rates are increasing very
very rapidly indeed but that is not
causing the province to consider new
restrictions amid increasing social
contacts the province believes hospital
capacity and icus can manage the surge
in cases knowing that we have the
capability in our hospitals to to manage
this
this is something that we're sure that
we're going to be able to get through
there's no cause for panic that this was
anticipated but as fourth doses become
available across the country it's not
clear most canadians will get it less
than half the population has even
received a third dose and as society
opens up at the same time a highly
transmissible variant is spreading third
shots are seen as the most urgent
measure we've got to stop thinking of of
the third dose as being a booster this
is really a disease that's turned out to
be a a three dose disease a three dose
vaccine disease province by province
there is growing divergence on public
health measures quebec is worried enough
that it's extended its mass mandate for
public places until at least the end of
april we have to wait and see how the
progression of this wave
will
will be while provincial governments are
approaching public health measures on
different timetables they remain in
lockstep on their best advice to keep
the pandemic in check don't discard
those masks and do get caught up on your
booster shots eric sorensen global news
toronto